welcome back now I think we can now
hopefully you have some intuition and
and maybe you can figure this out on
your own but I'll show you how to do it
we spend a lot of time on how fast did I
throw the ball you know how fast was it
when I left my hand let's figure out how
high did it go because that's kind of a
cool thing to know as well so we we
figured out that the final velocity the
final velocity or actually the initial
velocity is just equal to minus the
acceleration of gravity times time over
2 right if we say the acceleration of
gravity is minus 10 meters per second
squared then this becomes 5t right so
that's the initial velocity so we leave
with and then the final velocity is just
the negative of the initial velocity
right going back to what we were doing
before right
so the initial velocity we want to
figure out how high did we go so let's
just go back to our basic we want to
figure out this point we want to figure
out how high did this thing go right and
that's actually the vertex of this
parabola and if you know the formula for
vertex of parabola you could you could
do it but once again I like to do it
intuitively as opposed to memorizing
formulas so we want to figure out how
high did this go it's call that H so
what happens I'm going from I'm going
from an initial velocity of VI
and I'm going to a final velocity a
final loss I'm going you can kind of
call this in an intermediate velocity we
go to the velocity of zero and it takes
a time of T sub naught over 2 that
doesn't look too good but it takes let's
say well let me it takes T over let's
say that this is this is it takes T over
2 or T sub naught over 2 I know it gets
confusing when it's T sub naught T sub
naught just says this is an actual
constant T as opposed to just the
variable T that's all it is I know get
confusing sometimes so the initial
velocity is equal to minus G times you
know whatever we time whatever your
friend gets on the timer but we also
know that between the initial between
time 0 and time T sub naught over 2 so
half the time that your friend has on
the timer the velocity went from this
will
so d20 right so the average velocity
over that time not the average velocity
over the entire time the average
velocity over just this first interval
right the at the average velocity here
would just be so this it would be V sub
I plus zero right because we're kind of
this intermediate velocity plus zero
because we're stationary up here and we
divide that by two right well V sub I is
just this so if we take this and
substitute it here we get their average
velocity over the average velocity over
this time interval is equal to minus G
times T sub naught over four now so
remember this is only the average
velocity over this time period the
average velocity over the entire time
period over T sub naught is actually
zero because we start and end at the
same place and that this is kind of an
interesting point as to what how speed
and velocity is different you're
probably thinking hey Sal how could the
average velocity over the entire time be
zero when the ball was clearly going
quite fast most of the time well that's
the difference in speed and velocity it
turns out that the speed was I agree
with you quite fast the entire time but
when you take the average velocity all
the times that the velocity was positive
is balanced off by the times that the
velocity is negative so over the entire
period the average of the velocity is
zero and that makes sense because the
the ball didn't go anywhere right it
just came back to where it started so
that's that's an interesting distinction
between speed and velocity but anyway
going back and I hope I'm not confusing
the average velocity over this time
period is minus G times the T sub naught
over four and if we were to graph it
here that would be right here it would
be it would be essentially this it would
be this it'd be this point
right this is our average velocity over
half the time period and it would be
equal to V sub I over 2 which is equal
to this right so there we know our
average velocity over this time period
and we also know the time the time is T
sub naught over 2 so we can just say
change in distance is equal to average
velocity times time well what's the
average velocity it's - it's all this
stuff
- - gee t sub naught I hope you can read
that that's T sub naught over 4 so that
is let me switch some colors just so so
the average velocity is this and what's
the time we're saying the average
velocity over T sub naught over 2 not
the whole T T sub naught not the holes T
sub naught and maybe if I do some
examples with numbers this won't be as
confusing so the time is T sub naught
over 2 so T so I'm not over - that's the
time and so the distance we traveled so
this distance H is equal to if we
multiply it out - gee T sub nought
squared over 8 so that's interesting if
if I throw a ball so this is H and I
know I'm making this really crowded if I
throw a ball and it takes let's say it
takes 5 seconds 5 seconds to go all the
way up and go all the way down right
then if I just substitute in this
equation so it takes 5 seconds to go all
the way up and all the way down and once
again this is minus G so if gravity is
actually a minus 10 meters per second so
this is becomes a positive so going back
if I say let's see H is equal to so
minus G
is positive 10 meters per second times
let's say it takes 5 seconds I think
that's just what I said 10 times 5 over
8 so 40 over 8 it equals 50 oh sorry t
squared I was about to say something
that's not right
T squared right there's a minus GT
naught squared over 8 so what's 10 times
25 its 250 over 8 250 over 8 so that's
30 30-something meters what is it 240
it's like 31 meters so if I can throw a
ball and it stays in the air for a total
of 5 seconds
I throw 31 meters in the air that might
not sound high but that 31 meters is
what 90 feet or you know 9 93 feet and
that's equivalent to a nine story
building so that actually is pretty high
if you can if you can keep a ball in the
air for for four or five seconds you're
pretty strong but I want to show you
something else that that's kind of
interesting at least interesting to me
let me erase some of this just because I
think it's getting a little really crazy
now let me erase this stuff
she held even erase this stuff I think
you you get it now you can just back up
and rewatch it if you ever that's the
beauty of these videos you don't really
have to take notes you can just back it
up and rewatch the video let's see okay
I think I have a lot of clean space now
so let me switch to a nice color
okay and back to the pen tool okay so we
got this we got that the height is equal
to minus G T naught squared over eight
right but we could have also written
this as and I'm just playing around with
this algebraically this is the same
thing as minus G minus G over two times
T naught squared T naught over two
squared right this is just this is the
exact same thing and I was watering just
does this does this concept does this
look familiar
well sure this is in our in our distance
equation that we did before where we
just say that that change in distance
change in distance is equal to the
initial velocity times time plus a T
squared over 2a T squared over two so
this term right here looks a little
awfully lot like this term and this
would be equivalent to this equation if
this initial velocity was zero so how
does this relate well another way to
think about it is this distance that
you're traveling right this distance
that we're traveling up it's also the
same distance maybe you know just the
negative of the distance that you travel
down right so if we said that we're
starting at this point right we start at
this point and at this point the ball is
stationary so it's identical to just
taking that ball and
dropping it right so if we say that
we're going to drop a ball from height H
how long does it take well then we can
use this formula if I drop a ball from
height H so the change in distance is
going to be minus H because it's going
to go from height H to zero right so we
could say minus H is equal to the
initial velocity is going to be zero
whoops I'm overtime